well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so then we'll
see what's making the headlines
with the communications advisor former
aide to boris johnson guitar harry
and the journalist and podcaster leslie
riddick great to see you both
to the front pages before we get your
thoughts uh the eye then has word that
60 million doses of the
novovax cover jab will be manufactured
in the uk
easing concerns about possible problems
with imports from the eu
the daily mail seems to think the
government aren't moving back to
normality quickly enough
asking what are we waiting for while the
times
leads on reassurance from the prime
minister that the plan to ease lockdown
remains
on course for shops and pubs to reopen
in two weeks time the telegraph carries
a joint suggestion
from the leaders of britain france and
germany that there should be
a global treaty to prevent and protect
against future pandemics
the metro has the headline nine minutes
29 seconds
reflecting the amount of time it's
alleged police officer
derek chauvin spent with his knee on
george floyd's neck
mr chavin's trial began today in the u.s
the guardian hears there are calls for a
wide-ranging investigation
into sexual abuse in schools by the
regulator ofsted
after a website for survivors was
inundated
with thousands of allegations the delhi
mirror again
leading with details of the alleged
relationship between boris johnson
and the american businesswoman jennifer
r curie
the financial times offers warnings of
large expected losses
from the investment banks namura and
credit suisse
so guitar and leslie riddick here um
different headlines has to be said but
you've picked to start with the
daily telegraph which is really
interesting isn't it gito world leaders
calling for
a pandemic treaty saying this is the
biggest challenge to face the world
since the 1940s and and needs to be
dealt with thus
yes it's a refreshing story for so many
reasons eh because there seems to be
cooperation on the story itself across
newspapers across countries and all that
but it really is a sign of great
maturity i think that we're behaving not
in a sort of
selfish short-term and rather unseemly
fashion
grabbing as much of a vaccine as we can
and depriving everyone else
of it there does seem to be a move among
the key players in the world to make
sure that the entire world is inoculated
and that we have some sort of
uh code of conduct if you like at a
global scale be called something much
grander than that going forwards
uh and in the end of course it it goes
back to a core moral
principle that what what actually does
benefit
each of us individually in the end is
what benefits the whole and to see that
happen on
on an international global level
potentially is extremely exciting
yes and the daily telegraph leslie
pointing out that this
joint article comes in the wake of
disagreement between britain and the eu
over the production and distribution of
vaccines
that is one element but transparency is
also one of the words they call for
which goes back to the origins i guess
of this and whether we will ever find
out
how this coronavirus began in wuhan and
spread around the world
yes but um it looks like the the
initiative is really the world health
organizations and the other leaders have
decided to fall in behind it
i mean it is really quite extraordinary
because the rest of the stories that
we'll probably spend some time talking
about
are entirely about if you like vaccines
slightly one-upmanship or or at least
the concern that we've got enough to to
go around
and the key thing that they're looking
at here these 24 world leaders
um is to bring countries together dispel
the temptations of isolationism
in the wake of a pandemic and they're
drawing all sorts of
comparisons with the period after the
second world war
i mean you could if you want if you've
got 24 leaders in a room and they're
beginning to be able to think like that
there's a lot more in terms of
reconstruction and a green
reconstruction that you could start
thinking about
um beyond the the aims of the vaccine
important in the short term though they
be yes
you make a very good point going back to
domestic
vaccine supply the telegraph saying last
night which is today obviously mr
johnson announced his latest move
to ensure the resilience of the uk's
domestic vaccine supply chains
amid the threat of trade wars which
takes us to the
geeto uk vaccines boost so this is the
bottling
of the novo vax doses will now take
place in britain
instead of the european union they've
clearly been working hard behind the
scenes
yes very hard to get it sort of uh over
here so that there's no question of any
blockade getting in the way whether
that's politically motivated or just a
result of
you know confusion at the border um
there's a nice little twist to it that
the uh
the production is going to be of all
places bernard castle somewhere
some people in parts of england will
know
well as a beauty sport the rest of us
know of it as the place where
uh certain dominick cummings went for a
walk uh or to test it as eyesight or
whatever but
a happier association if you like for
that part of the north of england
that it's going to make us more
resilient and make sure that we can
carry on going what they say number 10
is sort of gangbusters on vaccinating
people
absolutely dating updates as we all know
um and and we hang on to every date
clearly don't we
um the daily mail asking what are we
waiting for
as these in uh the infection figures
come down there it is the mortality
that's really coming down isn't it which
is
what we told we're told was going to
come first with the vaccines working
so effectively um but leslie what do you
think about
daily mail running a piece like this
trying to urge the road map to be
speeded up
well of course this is the point where i
have to point out that i'm speaking to
you from scotland
and uh our is totally different
so we don't get any of this sort of
unlocking down really till april the
26th
um and in many respects it feels like
we're just a little behind the kind of
exuberance thing and they sometimes
they um well you know the optimism that
then gets followed by having to kind of
pull back the horns so the the the
outlook in scotland's generally being a
lot more cautious
and yet um clearly there's been a bit of
survey work done that suggests that most
people
in any part of britain are about one
step ahead of whatever regulation
they're supposed to be abiding by at the
moment
so the the the restrictions are already
being stretched
to what we're about probably to be able
to enjoy officially
so um i can see that there's a head of
steam
developing maybe this is just my
inherent cautious scott
but i'm just still canny i'm quite happy
to just
let this run a little bit longer and
keep the phasing going on that we've got
north of the border so that we don't
have everybody effectively unlocking at
the same time
yes that's interesting although the
phasing still does exist
south of the border does it not um
guitar as we heard
from the chief medical officer
scientific adviser and the prime
minister today
caution is still the watch word and the
problem is
that those who are most likely to get uh
and
uh pass on the virus are those who are
not vaccinated
yeah and i don't blame the prime
minister or the government certainly
in england for being cautious but
neither do i blame uh
the press and and some of us who are
less cautious in our nature perhaps
uh of being a little impatient straining
at the leash at the moment my fear
is that we have vaccinated 30 million
people
deaths have fallen to a a tiny fraction
of what they were and yet
very little so far has changed in the
big calculations and in the behavior and
it's a little bit
uh like that wonderful scene with morgan
friedman in uh
shawshank redemption where the prisoner
is told that he can leave prison and he
doesn't want to he's got so used to
being incarcerated and that's the danger
with
the uk now is that people you know
are free on soon will be free and the
government has more room for maneuver
now than it's had for a while but it's
still
over cautious so i see both sides of the
argument but instinctively i'm with
those
who want to go further and faster yes
what i'm surprised about is that they
don't stress that we're all dealing with
this kent variant the b117
with its extra transmissibility and
presumed mortality which is a main
factor i think for the
slowness of the road map um but what
many people will be discussing today
is that new briefing room cost costa
penny as we know daily telegraph has a
picture of it
uh so your assessment then um what did
you think did it
look better did it make the government
look more efficient and presentable did
they look comfortable leslie you first
well uh they've cut the union flags down
from four to two so it's a little
bit less completely overwhelming those
of us who are
uh just just a bit funny a bit odd to
have the union jack absolutely
everywhere
um i think there's been a bit of a
change in the front and there was some
lettering which
uh apparently was a slightly scrambled
and has been replaced by a logo
but apart from that how you can find 2.6
million pounds worth
of of investment in that room totally
beats me
as i'm sure it does most people gita
this is your this is your
your home area is it not um as a
communications advisor what do you
reckon
well you're always going to get
clobbered for spending more than you
know the price of this and most houses
on on one room with a few flags in it
but in the end it's the technology
in that room that is critical and having
labored as a journalist the number 10
for years with nowhere to go uh
you know to the toilet um literally you
know
holding things together sometimes by
string or certainly gaffer tape
it's about time that we have a proper
press center at the heart of government
here where you can broadcast live to the
world and things
are more seamless and i'm sure over time
those people who
struggle with the technical side of
bringing all the news to us will
will inform the rest of us how much
easier this has made life and we may
think that 2 million quid
was quite well spent in that sense
because it enables our leaders to be
accountable and
that matters okay and we will await
obviously the the press briefings
after the may elections uh no doubt uh
we will hear more from you in just a
moment still to come
allegations of endemic sexual abuse in
schools we will
talk about more uh more about that in
just a moment
you're watching the press preview with
me now leslie radick and guitar harry
welcome
back oh i was going to say welcome oh
there you are lovely you disbed for a
moment um
so let's take a look shall we leslie at
the guardian
which is calls for an urgent inquiry now
into serial school
sexual abuse after the numbers of pupils
who had listed concerns has gone
up exponentially hasn't it
yes and this is i think this is
fascinating because to any of us of a
certain age
this is like a rerun of child lines
establishment all those years ago by
esther ranson
which again at the time nobody took this
seriously and it took a real campaigning
journalist to
spend the rest of her life actually
campaigning on just this issue
and here's this young woman soma sarah
who set
up this website everyone's invited after
her own experiences of what
she called a rape culture she's just i
think she's in her early 20s
and she was inundated on on social media
with other people's experiences of the
same thing
she decided to move to this website and
has got something like 5
000 accounts on it now from from
children some of the girls are as young
as nine
and they're talking about uh in fact
there's been a walk out i see from a
school in
london where the pupils have said
they're just sick of the the kind of
sexual intimidation that's going on
and of course now there's bigger
discussions too because um
[Music]
feeling a bit targeted as well this this
is
generally one-way traffic but you know
some of the schools that have been
looked at
and and some of these elite boarding
schools have been in the focus too
gordon is one prince charles famously
said of it it was called it's in kilts
you know so
there's lots of boys have felt extremely
constrained in the
in the sort of atmosphere of some
schools as well
and this got to be taken seriously yes
we obviously don't have the schools on
to defend themselves but
certainly the guardian says as they move
forward with this after the everyone's
invited
um idea which was was set up that a
special national helpline is expected to
be set up this week
uh that offsets should investigate as
part of a deep dive inquiry
so no doubt we'll hear more about that
in the coming days but
with our time left do you mind if we
move on gito to the uh
the ship uh just what extraordinary
pictures these are
um in the metro finally the ever given
freed after
a monumental effort
yes i i've loved the whole story of this
ship i've been slightly
you know obsessed with it the idea that
a ship you know the size of
four football fields or longer than the
shard in london is tall and the shard is
europe's tallest uh tallest building can
actually just somehow
jam this huge artery through which a
massive proportion of world trade flows
and cause tarnish
change the price of oil change you know
patterns of behavior across the world
it's been fascinating there's a real
sense of triumph and well done to those
engineers
who somehow have managed to dug this
monster out of
whatever sand bank is it was stuck in
but it's going to have repercussions
for the way companies do business
there's been interesting things over the
last few days about how supply chains
will change and how
we will buy from different places we'll
hold on to more goods
all of it because one great big ship
where the captain who's going to be
mortified
and infamous for the rest of his life
actually managed to block the entire
canal
yeah you get ever given you get the
pandemic you get brexit it's all
changing is it not uh in the way we do
business lovely to have you both on
leslie kito we will see you for more at
half eleven thank you